it's recording now so we are very happy
to have Christians Schaffner tell us
about the basics of quantum cryptography
beyond qkd and and this is yep so I'll
just hand over the mic T all right thank
you very much well I'm happy to to get
the opportunity to recycle some of the
stuff are lying around and also like
tell you a little bit about quantum
cryptography and the reason why there's
a beyond qkt here in the title is that
most of this material here is based on a
tutorial talk that I gave at a q IP so Q
IP is the quantum information processing
workshop which is basically kind of the
theoretical computer science side of of
quantum of the quantum computing world
and they always have like two days of
tutorials before the conference and why
I was giving one of those and and that's
also it was two years ago in Delft in
2018 and so most of the stuff I show
here is kind of maybe say two years old
so some of that is slightly outdated in
particular like some open questions have
been solved and some of the focus has
shifted but I try to point out these
things so yeah and whenever you have
questions please ask immediately I can
see the chat and I can just undo just
unmute yourself and ask questions I
guess we'd keep this on a rather
informal level here so what I did when I
was asked to give this tutorial I did
this I kind of wrote everything I know
on my whiteboard of quantum crypto and I
also asked people for my group I guess I
hope you can see it can see my mouse
pointer as well see some people nodding
to to kind of contribute and yeah if you
try to make such a mind web it's quite a
and this was quite a mess and so I try
to structure this a little bit and you
will see that coming back in
I also want to point out one of the the
resources here and you were gonna come
back to this picture it's it's a survey
article that I have written together
with an broadband and it's now from 2015
so but still it contains some of the
classics also some stuff I'm going to
talk about in this talk and it's aimed
at you guys so it's aimed at computer
scientists so it's it doesn't require
much quantum to start with but it yeah
it's it's not it's not written for
physicists but it's I think you are the
target audience of this and you can just
find it on the archive and you can also
actually find the slides and almost
everything on either my home page or
archive so this is something I can I can
remind you recommend you to look at then
another thing I will quickly want to
mention is the cue crypt conference
series so that's not qi p but it's kind
of the small sister if it's cryptography
conference and this year will be the
tenth edition of the of the conference
it has kind of a similar format it's
gonna be organized i'm co organizing it
together research fear in amsterdam and
at the moment it's very unlikely that it
can actually physically take place
because it's planned for the beginning
of august but if not so I think actually
today is the submission deadline but if
not we will hold it electronically and
virtually as many conferences - like
you're equipped for instance online so
you kind of look at how that what they
are doing and see what the best format
is to do these things and then we will
probably organize exist physically next
year still in Amsterdam so we can
recycle a bit of the Berkeley yet so the
series has been started by a Matthias
Kristin Dole and Stephanie Wayne there
in 2011 so this year is gonna be the
tenth edition it's it has approximately
unread submissions some of them like a
third accepted as contributions last
year in Montreal there were about 300
participants and the goal is to
represent that year's best result equal
to
geography so in general if you're
interested in kind of this area than
this it's a way to kind of see what
what's going on in these areas by
looking at the program of Q crypt over
the last year's and so one of the goals
is also to bring together like theory
and practice and experiment really means
like physicists that implement protocols
and this is often related to quantum key
distribution so most of the
implementation knowledge is in quantity
distribution then there's also tutorials
and about six invited talks so and again
these tutorials are actually a good
resource for you if you want to learn
more about a particular topic then
looking up old cue Crypt programs and
the tutorials that were given there
there will be no fear helpful things to
to do if you want to know and most of it
should be on YouTube otherwise let me
know if you have trouble finding
something I have I have some backups of
all sites as well alright so that's
that's more high-level information let's
get back to this to this picture and
also thanks to the people who helped
making it so what I did is I try to make
a kind of a mind map in a more
systematic way and this is something
that you can download here on this
github repository and it's yeah well
it's made using a tool and even the
tools still exist I figured out
yesterday for Chile could still edit it
and what I tried and is basically I I
put some stuff in boldface so this is
maybe a bit hard to see on this small
screen but you can just download the
picture and see so those are actually
experiments this is stuff that has been
implemented in practice and then also in
green I have some open questions so this
was goal of this tutorials also to kind
of show some open questions to the
researchers in the field and some of
them have have been answered in the
meanwhile so this is actually kind of
fun at least for me it was fun and maybe
I will do this more detail kind of to go
back and see what has actually been
addressed in the meanwhile and of course
the one area here is post quantum
classical crypto so that's basically
your where you're most of you are at
home and so I'm gonna focus on other
parts and I think well you can feel free
to contribute to that if you you want
but somehow there's like big the the big
kind of clouds in this in this picture
is the area up here where and we talk
about quantum advantage so this I kind
of coined that term before it was used
in the context of Supremacy claim so
this is it's more in the sense of like
what can quantum offer which we cannot
do classically so it's it's in that
sense and in the crypto world we often
talk about like information theoretic
security so this will be the first part
of my talk as well for instance quantum
key distribution is something that we
can can do if you use quantum
communication but which we don't know
how to do if you just allow classical
communication and so that's kind of one
big cloud up here so it includes qkd do
includes quantum money device
independence some some fun stuff touched
on then down here I have a cloud of like
quantum data and so that includes kind
of secure computation multi-party
computation secure two-party computation
I'm gonna cover that in this talk as
well but also stuff like like delegated
computation like how to operate how to
encrypt quantum data how to delegate the
computation to a quantum server so
there's been a lot of programs in this
in this area over the Oder since since I
made this graphic basically in the last
two years there's been a lot of
development here and then there's a
whole box up here and tools so this is
just a bit of a collection of other
areas that contribute towards quantum
crypto but there may be areas on their
own and there as well there have been
quite a lot of development
it's bit new tools coming up allowing to
do more stuff and then of course there's
the whole post called a crypto area
which is very active which you probably
know more than I do so that's kind of
the big picture and now I'm gonna go
over some of this sub areas it and if
you have any questions so so the first
thing I want to zoom into is like this
area up here and in particular the one
of quantum key distribution so so maybe
we can have a quick vote on like say who
would be able to describe the pp 84
protocol for quantum key distribution so
maybe you can use your yes and no
buttons in the participant window so I
can maybe maybe everybody can see it
actually you go to participants I guess
you have some green and red buttons and
he could say yes I would be able to or
we not raised his hand you can say yes I
would be able to describe the BP 84
protocol or no I would have no idea how
to do this I don't see any maybe you can
only raise your hands yes sorry where
are the red and where the options you
see 10 oh I see I only see a hand is
this is this a setting we need to let me
try to create a poll let's see I had a
question usually we have this buttons
now at least in my maybe it has been
disabled yesterday there were so the
question is can you describe you can
raise hands that's also I mean for just
yes or no questions you can under
reactions just do thumbs up I you have
okay
you have reactions down there in the
bottom
invite participants share screen chat
record reactions please for me that I'll
meet two options to both up and clap
that is not the no no option mission are
you gonna test people who say yes I well
aware show receipt is done I only see
people raising hands in that
participants list
we can yes what I can lower all hands
that's too bad it's really kind of
limited the interactions oh yeah okay I
see a thumbs up okay yeah I see some
clapping and some hands up but that
means like 4 out of 19 would be able to
describe this protocol if I take it down
I take this poll then maybe I couldn't
know where all your hands is that the
word all hands yeah at least Edward
alright so I will describe it to you
that's against the purpose of this talk
and for that I just need a little bit of
formality but this stuff I guess you've
seen so what I usually do it just use
two different colors like yellow and red
for these two the two bases so this is
there you've seen as computational basis
this is the zero state so in terms of
vectors this is just a one zero vector
and this the one state is the zero one
vector
these are basically denoting the two
directions you can have and in qkd and
often explain quantum communication
protocols you can really think of them
as the direction of the polarization of
photons so you take some photons of
light source and you put the polarizing
filter this is really nothing
spectacular it's really just say you
take a laser and you put your sunglasses
in front of them and just the way you
hold your sunglasses is basically
polarize letting light through that is
only polarized in this way and and then
of course you can turn your sunglasses
in depending on the angle you you put it
you can have different quantum states
and the difficulty to do it in practice
is that you have to use single photons
and so that then it becomes quite
annoying also to detect them
but in principle just like sending a lot
of photons is very easy you can do it at
home and so then in this red bit is like
the diagonal basis then we have this
state is the superposition of zero one
so this is that that's 0 plus that 1
over square root of 2 we normalize
and that's if you kind of do the linear
algebra well you get this diagonal
direction and you can if you subtract
the two then you get the other diagonal
direction so a global faces don't matter
that's why and at the arrows polling
point both ways so these are the basic
states I think most of you have seen I
hope and what you can do with them is
measure them so if you do measurements
so we will denote this here as a
measurement in a computational basis say
if you take the one state and you
measure it then the outcome is a
classical bit and in this case it will
always say that the outcome is one so
with probability 1 you will get outcome
classical 1 and nothing will happen to
the state and more interestingly if you
take such a state in the yellow basis
and you measure it in the the wrong
basis and the other one well it's going
to happen what you've seen is that with
probability 1/2 you're gonna get a 0 and
the state is actually changed to the one
that you observed so the the the state
has changed to two what you've seen
namely to that and this probably 1/2 you
get a 1 and you changed it to the other
step so so am i okay with assuming that
people have seen this before
so the basic yes ok so um and that's
that's more or less what we what we need
and of course you can operate on this on
these quantum states by doing unitary
operations an example of it is the so
called Hadamard operation which is just
kind of transforms this once from on
daisies to the others or how the March
is kind of it's a particular rotation
you do but for instance if you apply a
ha demarcate on the zero state you end
up in a zero state in the other basis
and it's self inverse if you do it again
you will flip back to the other basis so
so that's the quantum operations unitary
transforms that you can do now for
quantum crypto a very crucial ingredient
is the so called no-cloning theorem
so the no-cloning theorem it says the
following it says take one of these four
states at random so just pick flip two
bits and
kind of pick one of these states at
random that's that's denoted as this
question mark and we try now to make a
perfect copy of that state so basically
you want a cloning machine so this is
Dolly the sheep let me know how to clone
and we were just wanna have a machine
that kind of makes a copy of these two
states right and the no-cloning theorem
basically says that we are not allowed
to do that so we cannot perfectly clone
a quantum state and the proof of this is
very simple I'm going to show it to you
on the next slide basically it's because
copying is a non-linear operation so
have you seen this as well
this was an assignment problem in one
other very good so for those who did not
do the assignment here is the solution
because there is a very simple proof at
least for the perfect case so here's how
you can prove it
so assume such a cloning machine exists
so I assume a unitary transformation
such that for all any state you put in
and if you apply this unitary to that
state so here you have this state and
you have some helper cubed some
auxiliary qubits just to as kind of a
placeholder you initialize it with zero
but you want that in the second register
you end up with a copy of that state and
so a perfect cloning machine you would
do this it would map any state into the
state itself plus a copy of it an
intensive product so and then we want to
find a contradiction to that so in
particular if you do this on the zero
state well then you're gonna get you're
gonna end up with two zeros if you do it
on one state then you would end up with
two ones so that's that's what happens
if you if you copy either 0 or 1 state
and now we do it on the superposition of
these two so by linearity of you so
contem operation always has to be linear
if we try to copy this state 0 plus 1
and now I always left out normalization
switch it sometimes the beginning is
very confusing to to to beginners but
somehow it's it's it doesn't it helps
not to clutter the notation but in
principle you would have to normalize
this by dividing by the by the square
root of 2 but if you if you apply that
here then you can put you here and you
there so so you get you of the first
part plus you of the second part and now
we just know what you should get because
we've done this above here so you should
get 0 plus compute 1 but that
unfortunately is not the right answer so
this is not the state that we want
because this is a copy machine so what
we actually want is that you should end
up with a 0 plus 1 tensor a 0 plus 1 but
if you if you kind of multiply this out
and using the properties of the tensor
product you will not only get these 2
terms here that you
that you get by linearity but you also
have this kind of cross terms and so
these two states are really very
different from each other and so this is
a contradiction because this contradicts
our assumption that you was actually
copying any steps I showed we showed
that if it does copy zero and it does
copy one well then it does not copy
properly copy zero plus one so if it
works in one basis it cannot work in the
other and that's a very typical thing in
the whole quantum world that somehow you
always play with this complementarity of
these bases note for instance that this
actually says that well you can have a
copy machine as long as you only do it
in in one basis in a computational basis
because then everything is classical and
you can actually make a copy out of a
classical bit and we do it all the time
but if you have something that works
perfectly in that basis well it cannot
work in the other basis if you have to
respect linearity and so and so so we
have a problem here and this this shows
at least a perfect copy machine is not
possible in the quantum case and of
course one needs to use quite a bit more
refined methods to to actually use that
in practice but somehow in spirit is it
really that that kind of enables a lot
of a lot of crypto ask you as you will
see you now yes this is veno the
question a you said if I know that the
vector is in the standard basis and of
course I can clone right but if I know
that it's close to the standard basis
and angle between the state and the
basis is small then can I sort of clone
and how well can I clone yes yes you can
all update so there are that are it
works up to some degree so there are
approximate cloning machines and you can
say you can specify exactly how well
they do
so there's trade-offs from like if you
do that well in one basis then you
cannot do that my god and this can fully
specify but it's not well is T so even
if you know that exactly it's not the
tool that you're gonna use say in
security proofs you kind of use other
takes tricks in the end you of course
also refer to the linearity of the
quantum operations you are allowed to
perform but there are a kind of better
suited tricks to show security okay but
of course people have studied just from
a physics point of view like how well
can you actually clone so right yes you
can you cannot do it perfectly but you
can do it up to that degree but often
these things are not are not very useful
but you can maybe you cannot use it for
security proofs but you may use that as
a stick as an operation in a
cryptographic system cloning
approximately if the graphic tool calls
for that yeah I mean that's an idea so
you would kind of try to exploit it as a
as a tool for the on display or saying
yes yeah no I'm not aware of it and
often maybe that's also something we're
gonna see a little bit back later
especially if you want to map it back to
the classical world we really want kind
of close to perfect correctness now in
crypto we want our correctness errors
maybe even security errors to be
negligible ideally and that's often not
what we get from the quantum case so
which makes it which renders it kind of
useless or at least unclear what you can
do with it depends on the application
yeah depends on the of course yeah it's
always yeah indeed so if you were if you
kind of define the application to be
okay with this kind of error and then
fine yes maybe even desire this kind of
John
I'm not aware of an application the
application of quantum money wouldn't
you care
I guess about like precise bounds on
this kind of thing you don't want the
adversary to give a constant state yet
like will pass verification but some
usually want something that's that very
have some some some type of parallel
repetition and property where you you
are okay with some error but then you
just do it with many qubits in parallel
and then the error goes down
exponentially right but that's often
very hard to show so this you know I
also come back to okay I mean I'm
thinking about more sophisticated maybe
a cryptographic type of operations and
if you want deniability of some sort
maybe you know even if you want to do an
oblivious transfer there would not be
useful I think I will talk a little bit
about all right also so so in terms of
time I think I will just go as slowly as
I can and try to make it as clear as
possible and then if we are out of time
and we can move some stuff to next time
it's a that seems to me the right
strategy so qkd so if you haven't heard
about it then it's really like it's kind
of the elephant in the room
at least from a physics point of view
that's the thing that people care about
what they implement and so I want to
spend some some time at least telling
you what it is and I'm gonna show you
the the bp80 for so the B P stands for
Bennett and pres are 84 version of it
and so how it works on a very high level
is basically Alice sent some qubits to
Bob and these qubits are really just
picked at random and from the four
states we saw before and then after that
they communicate classically so this
this dashed line here is a quantum
communication going from Alice to Bob
and then there's some classical
communication going between them and in
the middle sits the eavesdropper if and
she has control over all control over
the quantum line so she can interfere
with the quantum communication and but
she cannot
she can only listen to the to the
classical communication so the classical
communication is authenticated so she
cannot tamper with it but you can she
can listen to it
so that's the kind of setting and the
goal is to generate keys so these are
classical keys such as classical strings
that are identical and Eve as provably
know no knowledge about it so that's um
that's basically it so that's kind of
what it achieved so it offers a quantum
solution to the key exchange problem
which does not rely on computational
assumptions because one can actually
mathematically prove under the
assumptions that I mentioned that the
the really the information theoretic
knowledge that Eve has from the
tempering with this channel and from
listening to this classical
communication is is negligible about the
string a little Bob shared yet and as I
already said really the important caveat
here is that we need authentication
classical communication and
otherwise for instance you can just do
like like like in classical
diffie-hellman oh you can just play the
man in the middle so there you can
pretend to be Bob towards Ellis and
pretend to be Ellis towards pop and then
just like then to the standard man in
the middle attack there's no way to
prevent that using quantum but and then
the question is of course how do you do
this like how do you get authentication
and so what do what people do in
practice is they just use and so either
you can do information theoretic schemes
but then you need to start with the key
and to start with so they have to have
some pretty shared key which then by
quantum by using quantum key
distribution basically expand so if it
works if you will see I was showing more
detail the scheme works but somehow if
it goes through you can show that they
end up with more heat and I started with
but of course because Eve can has full
control over the quantum communication
she could just cut the line or introduce
a lot of errors and then basically they
will only figure that out while doing
the classical part and thereby they can
if can basically force them to run out
of this pre-shared key so so that's
that's a problem that that just is
inherent to the to the setting but you
can also do is just use computational
computationally secure authentication
schemes noticed digital signatures and
then of course the the whole that this
the whole security and properties of the
scheme is kind of downgraded to the
computational security of the digital
signature scheme however it has the
advantage that you have to kind of break
the digital signatures immediately while
this protocol is run so it's something
that you cannot kind of store and then
break in the future because if the
protocol has worked then the information
theoretic security holds so it's it's
what people have called an everlasting
security so somehow it's at the moment
you need the computational assumption
but if it has gone through and the
players can verify that then
security of the keys is forever then
you're allowed to give the the east
Roper an unbounded computational power
and even in that case they will not be
able to kind of figure out what the key
is
so that then you're kind of safe in the
future and this this is basically the
main selling point of qkd so this is
what qkd does it's it's it's able to
kind of turn a computational assumptions
that you have to that has to hold at the
moment into something that will hold
forever in the future so that's kind of
the cool thing that you can do with qkd
which you can actually provably you can
prove that you cannot do this if you
only allow classical communication so
that that's why it falls in this area of
kind of quantum at land it's just
something you can do in the quantum
world on you cannot do it in the
classical world any questions at the
moment but because I'm going to give
some more details how this protocol
actually works
but this is just this was on the high
level kind of what it achieves so so how
does it work well you actually do
exactly what I said before so what you
do is you you pick one of these four
states and how it's usually described is
Alice chooses a basis string so think of
it just as a random bit string so either
red yellow red yellow yellow and then
you also pick kind of the bits you want
to encode another independent random bit
string and then you do this encoding or
you encode the zero into the red basis
and you call it a1 into the yellow basis
and you end up with these qubits so
basically you just individually picked
one of these four states by choosing
these two bits and that's the thing that
Allison's over basically bit by bit
cubed by qubit to pop so now Bob um he
doesn't know what this basis is we just
picked at random by Alice and also from
these qubits you can actually not see
kind of what color they have so this is
a property of the quantum state so if
you've seen that but it's if you receive
those and the basis has been picked at
random there's no way for you to figure
out what that basis is in fact if you
picked one of these four states then to
you to Bob it looks like the completely
mixed state so that's kind of that the
way you would prove that Bob doesn't
know anything about these bits about
these qubits
so what he does is just picks another
random basis string so they might they
might match to the right color but it
might also not so it just picks a random
basis string himself and measures in
that basis so it does measurements of
these incoming qubits in these spaces
and what happens he got some outcomes
which is just again a classical bit
string and if the basis was correct so
for instance in his third and plays here
he measured this red qubit in the red
basis well then he gets the same outcome
as Alice was encoding at the beginning
so whenever the base is matched the
right color well then he gets the same
outcome as now is that but whenever they
was wrong we saw before he would just
get a random outcome now if you measure
a yellow qubit in the red basis you will
get a random
and sometimes this might match what
Ellie's ascent but sometimes might not
but he doesn't know that yet so what
they're gonna do is now classically
Alice tells Bob what is what his basis
was not not the beats that you encode
but just the base is used and now they
can compare now kabab can just say ah
see in this first two positions I used
the wrong basis roughly half of the time
he was lucky and guessed the right base
is half a time he did not and then it
just tells Alice look and his first two
positions let's forget about those
because I didn't measure in the right
basis again it doesn't say what he
obtained there so it just said Oh in
this first two positions our bases
choice didn't match so we have to forget
about these positions so just throw out
so basically half the pits position and
you end up with a string where you know
that you did you were using the same
basic strings and therefore you also
ended up with the same classical bit
string notice that both Alice and Bob
here are honest now so they are
basically playing together against the
east Roper so there's no like Oh what if
Bob cheats or so on because here just to
have two honest guys playing against so
in principle now you can so this is what
we call a kind of the rocky basically
you can now use those as the key but of
course it's not it's not that easy
because there's also the east so the the
eavesdropper yes she has control over
this quantum communication so
of course they just compared to the
classical bitstrings so that that part
Reema remains the same but it could be
that these qubits that arrived up here
Bob are not actually the ones that L is
sent so it could be that there's
additionally some errors in this in this
whole procedure but notice however we
can already see that from Eve's point of
view these are basically these these
unknown qubits it was picked these
qubits were picked at random out of the
four states and now basically the
no-cloning on a very high level the
no-cloning theorem applies
she cannot simply make a copy of these
qubits now because they are uh no qubits
to her she cannot classically that's
that's kind of where the different comes
in between the quality communication and
the classic if this was just classical
as a nice trope you can simply make a
copy and then just do whatever this
bought us and there will be no way to
generate the key from this quantum any
you don't know you cannot make a copy of
these qubits that fly by and in fact if
you try then you will introduce errors
that's kind of the the crucial point so
if if you try to make a copy and that's
actually the kind of the trade off maybe
also that we know it was anything yet so
even if you try to kind of get some
information out there what you what you
do is you introduce some errors in the
qubits that are sent and that's
something that the honest players can
check so in fact the quantum key
distribution goes on and they basically
kind of do some additional checks so
there's some more classical
communication going on between Alice and
Bob where they basically compare some
more positions of the remaining string
whether it agrees so they basically do
some some checking of how many errors
were there and that also means they will
have to sacrifice some more positions
and and then use error correcting codes
these are just classical error
correcting codes and classical privacy
amplification to basically get rid of
whatever is knowledge was so maybe even
concrete and then from that you can
extract the key even more concretely
maybe because some of you might be
familiar with this so this is just
basically information theoretic
key agreement protocols you start
basically at that point like before
maybe around here you have actually some
shared information between Alice and Bob
and if has some quantum side information
of that now the whole goal is to use
some information theoretic classical
procedure and it's as I said is you
basically do error correction and you do
privacy amplification and you have to
show that both of these steps work and
even though an eavesdropper has
quantified information so there's going
to be a step ready compare errors and
they actually there's some threshold and
say if the error is low enough then
we're then we're good then if doesn't
know too much about what has been
communicated and we can extract the
secure key or they decide oh there were
too many errors so if somehow the error
rate is above a certain threshold say
only we have to stop we have to try
again
because if might know too much about
what has been communicated and then you
basically you have to restart
yeah so that's that's basically the
high-level outline of our quantum key
distribution works and as I said before
the talk this it can take up to a whole
semester basically to learn a full
security probe of that just because you
need some quite a bit of quantum
information theoretic tools to model
this is you need to kind of have meaning
for mini-mini entropy about these
strings given some quantum side
information and then after you show that
privacy amplification like basically the
left over Herr Schlemmer also works
against quite quantum sign information
you have to come with the proper
security definition etc so it's it's
yeah it's quite involved to to actually
get a security proof of this just looks
like an OT protocol also because Bob
could just convey the places that he had
the wrong basis and choose write as a
set where he doesn't very good exactly
that's exactly actually what where I
where I want to go to later in my talk
and I realize I'm already taking a lot
of time but maybe I don't know should I
speed up because I I can also go much
faster or it just maybe I think some of
us have to live in live at the one hour
mark okay all right then maybe so so
this is a quick point that actually
quantum key distribution you can
actually do technically because you
don't need to do quantum computation all
right so there's no quantum computers
involved basically you can generate
these photons and measure them upon
reception you don't need to store any
quantum information so that's that's why
you can actually buy boxes that do this
quantum key distribution they look
something like that's their optical
fiber connecting them and this is so far
that yeah you can buy it and therefore
you can also hack it so there's the
quantum hacker that Vadim Makarov is
famous for opening devices and
destroying them and he actually built an
eavesdropping device that he took as a
hand luggage through airport security to
actually show kind of real-life attacks
on
on actual qkt systems so right so this
is a third kind of a three-party
scenario and I already described it it's
an advantage because you can show
classically that you cannot do this so
now I think the next thing I want to
focus is exactly that part with a
two-party so that's that's maybe the the
and the thing I want to cover still in
the time I have left so I want to talk a
little bit about two-party cryptography
and again in the setting with
information theoretic security and so no
computational assumptions and the
question is like so so so we want to
have protocols and I guess you're all
familiar with that that are correct so
if both players are following the
protocols then should do the right thing
but the same protocol should also be
secure for honest Ellis so if she's
following the protocol but Bob tries to
deviate and the other way around so if
if Bob is honest but if but Ellis tries
to deviate from world goal she should be
learning anything and so here there's no
eavesdroppers insist move from three
party to honest parties with these two
opposite versus just to party secure
quick I guess you're familiar with that
so the things I want to talk about our
coin flipping so that's kind of in the
in terms of usefulness starting from the
least useful and to be more useful like
bit commitment than previous transfer
and two-party function evaluation where
you can allow compute arbitrary
functions and and from that you can also
get multi-party computation at least
whether it is honest majority and you
are
I mean you are aware of that these
things so I can go quickly here so they
said well no so this is just classical
no quantum so if you if you have that
well then you can also do multi-party
and the other way round
and of course oblivious transfer is just
a special case of a two-party secure
function evaluation where Alice does not
receive output and Bob just gets the bit
of his choice and if you have ot you can
big commitment so that quickly and if
you have big commitment flipping and but
not the other way around so at least I
think it's not known how to here correct
me if I'm wrong how to if you have a
coin-flipping protocol how to be a bit
commitment it's also not classically
North Korea at least maybe you can even
show that you cannot do this transfer
based a bit commitment but ot is
complete so if you have a model where
you can do o T then you can also to
secure two-party computation and so kind
of the usefulness is is in here so
oblivious transfer is kind of a nice
measure of like if we have a cool model
do we have a model that is powerful
enough to do ot well then you can do
everything else that you're interested
in again information theoretic security
so what I want to add here is quantumly
there this implication is now so you can
actually so that's again a difference
between the classic on the quantum world
in quantum world you can upgrade bit
commitment to oblivious transfer and I'm
going to show you how how this works so
quantum early somehow the usefulness is
a little bit it starts earlier if you
have a model that can become can do bit
commitment then you can also do the rest
so I wanted to start with coin flipping
yeah I think I have some time because
there's also some quantum story here so
there's kind of two notions of coin flip
so there's the strong coin flipping and
that's maybe the two thing the regular
thing so no dishonest player can bias
the outcome so you want to make sure
that even if you cheat in this protocol
then you cannot kind of bias the outcome
towards one of the one of the outcomes
it's not so hard to see that classically
a cheater
you can always obtain your desired
outcome with probability one somehow
they could just kind of go back and then
there's always a way to kind of get to
what you want but there's a message that
allows you to kind of win but as
quantumly it's a bit different so there
are having protocols proposed that have
a bias so the bias is like how much you
can go away from one half of one quarter
and there's also been a proof of a lower
bound by this force for this bias for
strong coin flipping of which is a bit
below and by now so after a while
Shyu and candies have come up with an
optimal quantum protocol for strong
conflict which actually achieves this
bias in that sense it's this is close
now so we can't we can have the best
possible a strong coin flip it that bias
again may be in the spirit of Chevys
questions or like okay so what can we
use this for yeah so somehow it kind of
that's where it ends so if you want to
use if if your goal is to do strong coin
flipping then we know how well we can do
it but yeah have similar point to make
and on the next slide
finally in the quantum setting there's a
there's another thing which is called
weak coin flipping and so this is you
can always imagine as like who has to do
the dishes so somehow it's only like you
really care about one outcome so if say
if the coin show heads an ALICE then pop
has to do the dishes and otherwise it
and you really
Alice wants heads and Bob burns tails
and there there's been a long story of
of Carlos Monzon who kind of extracted
ideas from alexei kiev it's like a
quantum guy who doesn't like to write up
stuff himself but i mean it's kind of
people who extract ideas from him and he
had this whole theory of point games and
in in a series of paper you ended up
with with a suggested protocol which
achieves arbitrarily small by is epsilon
for for weak point flipping and these
people in like seven years later they
managed so this motions paper has never
been reviewed and it's been more than 80
pages so it has been reduced to 50 pages
but still not having an explicit
protocol but there's also been a bit of
a bit of progress over the last years
actually people have come up with
explicit protocols even though they are
pretty much numeric so it's still kind
of a mystery how this how this works
exactly but there are people in jeremy
Rowland's group in in brussels who have
kind of figured out this in more details
now and and and the importance somehow
you need these protocols to for instance
achieve the strong coin flip so the
strong coin flip with this optimal bias
it uses this week coin flip as a
subroutine so this all makes it quite
complicated too so these are i think
nobody has been able to really implement
this but at least we have better
understandings how these things network
so that's for that's for coin flipping
then 4-bit commitment of course so you
know what bit commitment is so it has
two phases you want to commit to a bit
say to alice has a bit in mind zero one
and then in the first phase you commits
in the second phase she opens and we
want that Bob's point of view gives
nothing away about this bit so it should
be hiding even if Bob is dishonest you
shouldn't learn what this bit is and it
should also be binding that I always
kind of change your mind anymore after
the commitment phase
and classically it's not that hard to
see that this is impossible because
basically you can look at this yellow
box here so either its information
theoretically hiding so it does not
contain information about a or its
information theoretically bindings it
kind of determines a but it cannot be
the same just at the same time so that's
basically why it's impossible to have
classically secure bit commitment and I
seen your son I raised her hand do you
have a question
I had a question about the previous
slide so I didn't get the distinction
between a strong and we can just ask you
later yeah maybe in the interest of time
I'll continue but I let's let's remind
me afterwards and quantumly
so finally people have thought that you
can have quantum bit commitment so
quantum protocol for classical bit
commitments actually for quite a long
time so people thought oh but quantum is
cool because you can actually do a bit
commitment and so they are division
published papers in Fox 93 about quantum
protocols for a bit commitment but those
turned out to be wrong because in 97
people realized that you can also not
have bit commitment in the in the in the
quantum case and for a very similar
reason basically it's just information
theoretically either the information is
there or it's not and this is actually
my suggestion that if people want to
study this I think for this reading
group it might be great to actually look
at one of these results because it
includes some very beautiful quantum
techniques like purification and this
Ullman CRM to just show the
impossibility of bit commitment in the
quantum case it's it's something good to
know and it's also something nice to to
prove so maybe if you can find some
volunteer to do that great then yeah it
doesn't depend on which definition of
bill commitment you know the impossible
no it doesn't okay no it really is very
general people have over and over tried
to kind of but then maybe doesn't take
this into account or that into account
no if you have used a randomness from
the stars maybe then possibility doesn't
apply so but this is okay alright you
really need some additional assumption
to get committee information theoretic
[Music]
so modular relativity and if you if you
start throwing in relativistic
assumptions then maybe you can do stuff
but yeah if quantum
and so here again this is this is maybe
for me I'm one of the prime examples
that if you allow some cheating
probabilities then you can do that in
the quantum case but these cheating
probabilities are quite high so they
show that in any
entree show you and your dynasty showed
that in any quantum bit coming in
protocol protocol one player can cheat
with probability zero point seven three
nine and they also give an optimal
protocol again based on this weak coin
flip that achieves this but so this is a
very imperfect bit commitment protocol
and the question is what should you do
with this so okay this is something that
you cannot do classically but also
that's the end of the story somehow you
you have to be happy with with that
because this does not compose at all so
you cannot use this to do something
useful in any of your classical
protocols because it has a huge error
probability so yeah if you're happy with
this as an end product then great but
somehow calling this bit commitment in
the sense of bit commitment for me it
comes with this association or it's
quite a powerful primitive because it's
often used in classical protocols to
force people to be honest etc but that's
only the case if it composes if it has
such a huge error probability in it will
not so so so this this is really not I
don't know I don't see much use of this
kind of very imperfect this treating
probability cannot be reduced and all
that because because that's even in the
statement shows that any quantum VC
protocol a player can cheat with that
probability so you could if you compose
yourself then it's still and then it's
still a busy protocol and and and so is
the cheating sort of cheating for hiding
or binding I think you know can I figure
out what the bit is with probability
point seven zero or I break binding with
either somehow you can have one secure
and then the other one isn't
or the other way around this is kind of
the trade-off point to someone where
they do it okay um the time oh it's two
minutes hmm what should I do
I think I should try to kind of get to
the point here of the stuff that you
don't know because this is just showing
how to do coin flipping from bit
committing is the Blum protocol that you
might have seen I hope you have so there
is some kind of very cute information
theoretic transformations between these
primitives and then oblivious transfer
you also have seen in this in the
variance in the various styles here so
maybe just kind of two quick comments
about this so this is standard oblivious
transfer one out of two oblivious
transfer to strings or bits as inputs a
choice bit and finally this has been
defined back in the in the very original
paper by Stephen visitor in 68 he has
this example one and means for
transmitting two messages either but not
both of which may be received so kind of
the very original definition of a
previous transfer goes back to this
paper of course he had no idea that this
would people would still would call this
previous transfer later on so it has
been rediscovered several times and also
with this name and show the usefulness
but still kind of that is exactly what
what you already had in this original
paper um and yeah so there's different
variants as Raven ot people have
realized that OD symmetric I think this
is still my record of the shortest paper
at your crypt or it may be at the crypto
flagship conferences just realization
that ot symmetric you know only has ten
pages I don't know if there's a shorter
paper at one of our conferences and and
now what I want to show is basically
what doc sheet set may be the quantum
protocol for pb's transfer because it's
very it's exactly what you realize
before this almost looked like a ot
protocol so if you did if you do what we
did before in qkd
you basically use the
beebee 84 states this quantum key
distribution state sent that and then
have Bob measuring a random basis then
and do the same like basis exchange then
at this point you can simply make two
sets of indices namely where you
measured correctly and very measured
incorrectly and so so imagine if you
want to build oblivious transfer where
now bob has a choice bit and he wants to
receive one out of two strings what you
can do is like just basically set the
index set of the positions very measured
correctly named as one set and a
complement of it other set tell these
sets to to Alice she also forms these
two sets and then they basically apply
some independent hash functions to kind
of converge this Rakhi into some
one-time pad key with which they can
hide the secrets that they want to set
kind of the inputs to the OT also you
basically just Alice fix two hash
functions of 0 and as f1 she maps she
takes these strings and hashes time you
can even think of like to a single bit
and then she uses this one time as a
one-time pad key to hide the bit 0 or as
found that she wanted to send originally
called is t0 and t1 and then of course
for those positions where Bob measured
correctly and if it does the same and
applies this hash function here then it
will recover that one time pad key and
so you can recover the just just here
the s-1 bits that Alice wanted to say it
seems extremely similar to the protocol
by crypto and Killian of how to use a
noisy channel to do miss transfer yes it
almost identical yes you are using this
noisy channel is comes out of the
quantum yes yes he there the noisy
channel kind of provided the
cryptographic resource that ensure the
errors here here it's the measuring kind
of in the wrong basis but of course we
are not quite done here so this is just
a suggestion of how the protocol works
in the owners case so let me see we have
to check correctness
so that's what I just described if the
both players are honest
well then it will work but of course we
have to check security and the easy case
is security for honest Bob so against
cheating Alice so in that case and we
want to make sure that Alice basically
doesn't learn
Bob's choice bit at least in spirit
that's what we need to show and the only
message that Bob sends to Alice is this
middle part but this is just these are
just random index sets because he's
honest so he's picked his basis basis
string at random no matter what alice is
sent as basic string this will two will
be two random sets independent of what
his choice but is maybe the order
depends on his choice bit but because
they're random Alice will not be able to
infer anything from these from these two
in this index sets so that that that is
the easy easy direction the other thing
is more tricky because security for
honest Alice we want to make sure that
an evil Bob he cannot learn more than
one of the one of the debates that were
sent that's more tricky because not what
what the dishonest Bob could do if he is
able to store all the qubits and simply
wait until Alice tells him the right
basis well then he can also obtain all
the all the bits or you can just obtain
the same string as Alice had so if he's
able to store these qubits for long
enough until the basis arrives well then
he also knows that string and you can
just recover the other bits as well so
we have to prevent him from doing this
and for doing that there are there were
there was the original suggestion of
basically using bit commitment to
basically force him to do these
measurements and the other suggestion
and that was part of my PhD thesis work
a long time ago is to use the so-called
quantum founded storage model or if you
just simply assume that they cannot
store all these qubits well then we're
also in good shape so I think I have a
few more details about this
but then I can also stop so so here's
the suggestion of how to how to use bit
commitment it's it's exactly the same
protocol as before
it's just what you're gonna do at the
beginning is the same Alice sensed is
bebe eighty four states Bob chooses a
random basis string he does the
measurement but what he does now is he
commits to the base E string and to the
outcomes that he received
so basically puts those in a in a safe
box and before they go on Alice does
some checks so Alice asks to open some
of these positions basically some
cottage juice so he opened some of these
positions as well in this case I was
measuring yellow bases I got zero here I
got one
and then you can be well so those you
have to get rid of these positions and
then you can be pretty sure or anyone
has to show that that means that he
basically also measured the other
positions and so you basically forced
him to do a measurement there and so do
not just wait until the right base is
announced so you can now announce the
bases and then do the rest of the
protocol exactly as before I do thanks
Ari okay so Chris yes so you know you
can get a big commitment from one way
function right you know some big
commitment from one way function sir are
you saying that one-way functions say
quantumly secure one-way functions and
replies oblivious plus quantum of course
quantum communication implies oblivious
transfer I so so I mean so how do you
get paid commitment from the one
difference oh yeah you can maybe one way
permutation that's that's these are kind
so I am going to come into a bit B I
pick a random string are I send you one
way permutation of are and then I pick
the hardcore beta for an XOR it with a
bit so that's hiding because of the
hardcore bet yeah right it's binding
because it's a one-way permutation so
you can't you know
I can't to reveal I need to give you are
but I you know there's only one hour
yeah yeah
everything is computational URL so
that's yes but you only need is a
one-way permutation right whereas
whereas without the quantum
communication I would need some sort of
like public key primitives and you know
some bizarre things you know right
but of course sort of question so we
started everything in the information
theoretic setting so if you have say
this works if you have you you see you
see bit commitment then you're in shape
but in the question is do you even want
to take the detour how you're saying you
okay so just from one way permutation
you cannot get oblivious transferring
the classic okay yeah exactly
I see I'm not sure if anybody has kind
of fully studied that
so actually Fang would be their
principal I don't see the the problem
with this yeah so quantum plus plus
one-way permutation should probably give
you OT mmm
yeah thanks I have to sign up too much
yeah you're welcome
alright maybe we should stop here I
don't know it's recorded or so so
basically I think I was more or less
done with this part I mean there's there
was just a addition yeah maybe I just
showed this one more slide and then the
summary event and so
the other option basically to to get
again to use the same protocol again and
prevent this one spot from storing all
the qubits is simply to wait because if
you wait a second on ten seconds one
second is probably enough that nobody in
the world knows how to actually store
these qubits for such a long time a long
time one second is a very long time and
for qubits to stay around and that
basically forces some measurement of the
dishonest Bob and then you continue with
the protocol so you do the same as
before and so in this kind of limited
quantum storage model where you're not
able to preserve a quantum state for for
a second one can also show again
information theoretically that you can
have bit commitment but also previous
transfer settings using exactly the same
so so as a summary in the in this
two-party crypto world
it's the added value of quantum here is
the implication from bit commit to this
transfer that's something that we don't
know how to do classical and I think I
will almost stop here today
thank you very much that that was a very
useful and very exciting talk works and
we're looking forward to the next one
okay so yes does anyone have any
questions I think maybe yeah Oxana I had
an urgent call
yeah she's gone I guess she was
wondering about the difference between
between weak and strong coin flip and so
you guys in the strong in the strong
case you you really want to make sure no
one of the players can bias in either
direction whereas in the weak coin flip
you really only care about one side also
one player cares for heads the other
cares for tails and you want to make
sure that they cannot buy is towards
that outcome so it's it's easier to
achieve great any other questions
okay I'm going to stop recording now